he's young ambitious and currently the
most sought-after man in the French
government Emmanuelle McConnell even
made a splash at the Hanover trade fair
in Germany
Frances economics Minister has proven
rebellious within his party ranks he's
arguably the darling of French politics
he knows what he wants
he's likable he's a breath of fresh air
in French politics so what makes the
former investment banker so appealing he
brings a lot of youthful optimism he's
the embodiment of positive change in
socialist policies it's not just about
making necessary concessions it's about
making the world a better place
president francois alone thought he was
banking on a visionary when he named the
36 year old mekin economics minister but
now a year before france's presidential
election things are not looking so
favorable for alone the number of
jobless is half a million higher than
when he took office unemployment is over
10 percent and to top it off he fears
his young Minister is stealing the show
especially in Hanover where he seems
very business-friendly mack kong
considers himself a reformer and he
doesn't hesitate to criticize a
cornerstone of french socialist policy
the 35 hour work week this isn't about
revisiting old taboos and obsessions
it's about giving businesses flexibility
sometimes you have to work more to keep
up with demand when there's work for
everyone and sometimes it's right to opt
for part-time employment with a recent
call to action a movement he's calling
all mouch McConnell aims to shake France
free from its culture of complacency he
could be the catalyst his country needs
to come to terms with everything wrong
in the French economy there are those
who want pure economic freedom
liberalism or even capitalism and others
who demand economic equality straight
across the board
I think there's a way in between its the
capacity to combine freedom and justice
almost 40% of French citizens say they
could imagine in manual McCaw as
president but it's daring bid to stand
directly between Frances right and left
amounts to a gamble in a country with
such strongly entrenched political camps
he's both he takes a page from the
liberal left playbook and another page
from the right that is the policies of
centrists and Republicans
he's a paradox and there's no way to
know how that will play out at election
time whether he has presidential
ambitions or not Macomb won't comment
but if there were a Ministry of
ambitions he'd be the one to run it